did you really think because I'm sure a
lot of people were like going hey he's a
good director he makes some cool [__] he
makes a cool horror movie makes this to
for a studio to give you a movie like
Guardians of the Galaxy
to say here
is
it just doesn't it seems unheard of that
they would be well it was his last movie
oh it was Memento okay let's give him go
or it was something huge something
whatever and it wasn't like you did
something that was a [__] home run
right it was good it was great but it
wasn't so had it so I know the story but
how hard did you have to push to really
get something like that to prove
yourself to prove your vision that is
gonna work I would say I pushed really
hard but also I didn't push hard at all
so it was a combination you know because
I was ready to quit directing you know
really 100 I was like listen I was
seeing how the tide was turning I was
seeing that you know they were stopping
making you know mid-budget films
um and that I always liked creating
things that were somewhat within the
zeitgeist
and I was seeing that most of the movies
that they were going to let me direct
the 30 million dollar movies were gone
and that everything was big Marvel
movies and they're never going to give
me that and yes I would love to do a
Hulk movie that was like big one at the
time uh you didn't think it was gonna
happen but I didn't think there was any
way it was going to happen even though I
met with Marvel a couple times about
little things I tried to get them to do
hit monkey I try to get them to do
something else I didn't think that they
were going to hire them they were going
to hire me for some big movie you know
so so I was like I don't think it's
gonna happen
I'm gonna Focus I see the future of
Television being really bright which I
was right about
um and I loved I just made a video game
that did very well and so I like doing
that so lollipop lollipops I was the
head of Nick I had no payments I love
that people still come up to me for
autographs so so it's like I had so I'm
like I'm gonna focus on television and
gaming that's what I'm gonna do I'm done
and I told my agent quit putting me out
for movies because I'm gonna focus on
television and gaming I just tried to
get some movie
um that they I couldn't get you know
which it seemed perfect for
um and then Marvel called up and said
will he come in we want to tell him
about this thing we're doing
and I was like God damn it you know
because Marvel's far away so at the time
not far now it's now it's in Burbank but
at the time it was in Manhattan Beach oh
that's an hour dude yeah and this is
like I was gonna have to drive home in
rush hour so I had to drive from Studio
City into Manhattan Beach so they could
pitch me and they could check me off
their list and they're not gonna it's
not really something that I'm Gonna
Wanna Do you think you're wasting three
or four hours I think I'm wasting four
hours of my day yeah right but I'm like
okay I drive down there I remember
stopping and getting a bite to eat
because I was early and talking to my
agent and or my lawyer Andrew hurwitz on
the phone
and being like yeah I mean I'm gonna go
on this thing is silly but
um when I go in there and then they
pitch me Guardians and
um and and that's really how it started
so it started like that and then you
know I've told the story many times
about how yeah yeah and came to me in
all this but I what I did was I worked
really hard like there's that speech
that um that Peter Quill gives in the
first Guardians of the Galaxy where he
says you know this is about giving a
[__] and that's what it was like for me
for the first time because I had
attributed All of My Success to really
hard work and not giving a [__] and I
allowed myself to give a [__] I allowed
myself to actually want to get this gig
and I sort of fell in love with the
concept of doing the Guardians of the
Galaxy I fell in love with I had always
wanted to do a Space Opera that was my
biggest dream to do a Space Opera in my
own way and I saw the opportunity here
and so I really worked hard and I
probably worked harder than anybody else
in terms of I wrote up this huge Bible
on what the visuals were going to be I
remember how I wrote a big I did
storyboarded the whole first sequence
from the movie
um and you know did a lot of work on the
characters that you know all this art
all these things it was harder to prep
this and get this so by the time you
went on set it was almost like probably
a little bit of a relief oh well yes on
this on the first Guardians absolutely
because you're prepared I was I'm increa
I'm incredibly prepared but also I
wasn't what I wasn't prepared for was on
the other movies I had done
I was
better at most of the department heads
than at their jobs than they were you
know I knew more about a lot of those
jobs than they did because I couldn't
hire the best and the brightest right
now there's obviously
um some great people I work with but
this was on a different level but
suddenly I'm making a movie for over 100
million dollars and I've got you know
just the greatest
um you know department heads and my A.D
was better than I was my you know uh my
camera operator has he been in the ad on
all three
no no no Lars is no Lars started on two
on two I love Lars who is now a DC
employee Lars who is now you know you
know running a lot of our production if
you love him he's was my age that was
the thing that I when I walked on set
the crew they were so amazing and your
DP sorry for memory lapse uh Henry Henry
Henry Bram who shot [__] he shot uh
you know Guardians uh three Suicide
Squad Guardians two he shot the flash
which people are gonna see is just one
of the greatest movies ever